conscious experiences are fundamental
right so
then in under that idea
mathematical structure is only about one
thing consciousness and conscious
experiences
and in that framework then you would
girdle would be telling us that there's
an infinite variety of
conscious experiences with an infinite
variety of different structures
and most of us have no idea that there's
anything else right this is the only
candy in the store and
and we're happy but this is one of the
boundless candies
and it's fun to wake up to that it may
be frustrating too if
we sit here and going but oh but i can't
experience them
and by the way even the mathematicians
based on girdle is incomplete disturbed
even the mathematicians can't abstractly
even begin
to explore just the mathematical
structures right
but by the way this is great job
security for mathematics this is
provable job security
this is you will never come to the last
theorem
never so this sign up for being a
mathematician
because you know that you have endless
employment
i'm not wedded to evolutionary game
theoretic
kind of model of the dynamics of
consciousness
i have to be open to a much wider
range of possible dynamical systems
right interesting
it's in general going to be simply some
kind of dynamics on graphs
it's really critical to walk away from
dogmatism
yeah right that's that's dogmatism is
the source
source of all this and you know it seems
like um
most spiritual traditions would
recognize that that humility
is a virtue and i would include
in that humility about my beliefs
humility that i could be wrong it's an
anti-dogmatic kind of point of view it's
more
um exploring and and
if we assume that we know then we cut
off inquiry
and we can't learn if you know if you're
certain that you know
then you're not going to be motivated to
learn someone's opinion may contradict
yours
where's my friend alan it's all about
your perspective
who are we and what is the nature of
this reality
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
i'm your host alan sakhyan
very pumped to be talking about
conscious agent theory we have dr donald
hoffman joining us on the show hi don
it's a pleasure thanks for inviting me
ellen very pumped for this episode
super excited for all that you're
pushing at the edge of what's known
for those who don't know don's
background he's professor recently
became emeritus
of cognitive sciences at uc irvine since
1983
37 years author of 120 plus academic
papers and most recently
author of the case against reality
proposing a conscious agent theory of
everything and you can find his links in
the bio below to his website
also his book the case against reality
as well as his twitter profile check out
all those links
all right don obviously we were both
extremely passionate about
metaphysics the nature of reality the
nature of being
the nature of consciousness and this
seems to be obviously
seems to be the most first principled
question that we must have children
and adults caring about but one of the
big arguments
that you propose is that the
the reality that that is that this is
actually makes it so
that we are tuned to not that fitness
function we are not tuned to the fitness
function of understanding who we are
metaphysics but we are rather tuned to
uh
getting fitness points and procreating
so you would
would you say that that is the the main
sort of
uh reason why there's so few people that
are studying
metaphysics nature of consciousness this
type of stuff
right so so yeah what i'm up to is
what we do in science all the time right
is we take our best current theories
and we push them we try to find out what
they entail
and we try to find surprising
implications of the theories and we try
to break them and that's the goal is to
push our theories to the limits
try to break them and and then we learn
something and then we try to go to the
next theory and so
that's what i'm doing with the theory of
evolution but natural selection i'm
really
just saying you know whether or not the
theory itself is true right
you know i'm not claiming that the
theory of evolution of natural selection
is true
it's the best tool we have so far it's
an incredibly powerful tool
we have nothing better so that's what
i've got to study and so the question is
according to that tool according to
evolution about natural selection would
we be shaped
to see objective reality whatever that
objective reality might be
and um most people would think
intuitively of course we
you know you know it makes you more fit
if you see the truth right if you mean
surely someone who sees
reality as it is is going to be more fit
um and have more kids than someone who
doesn't but
you know those intuitions are strong but
the math
of the theory of evolution of natural
selection is very very clear the
probability is zero
that any of our senses not just for
humans but for any creature
will ever be shaped to see any aspect of
the structure of reality
whatever reality might be so it's it's
it's
again i want to make sure it's clear
that this is from
from a scientist's point of view it's
not like i'm saying evolution is true
and you know deal with it i'm saying no
this is just i mean this is our best
theory so far
and we may come up with a better theory
but here's what our current theories say
and it's a surprise uh and and it's a
mathematical theorem
so if we don't like it we may need to
try to adjust the theory of evolution
with natural selection
or we may have to live with it and say
well no this is the way it is
this is very profoundly important
because when we look around
ourselves at the world at large we don't
see
people obsessively compulsively studying
truth and wanting to understand the
nature of reality
and a lot of the time we think that oh
well that's maybe based on the
economics and the incentive systems that
make it for people
to just funnel in as cogs into like an
economic machine
um and there's been lots of
philosophical conversations around the d
sacralization and the and the there's
not as much divinity not as much a
little bit more
nihilism maybe uh given today's
uh entrance into the ai age and so
this is extremely extremely important
that
children born to the world adults today
are wondering
what is what is consciousness what is
this awareness
do we share this conscious awareness how
do i study this word
that's infinity how do i study this word
that is eternity
what is a theory of everything what does
that even mean why should we care about
it
so part of it seems to be yes some
economical incentive
structures need to be pointed towards
that direction
for people to study truth rather than
just uh the procreation
and getting points um for in that sense
but also there's some overlap there that
that
um that we'll talk about in a little bit
would would you say that you know that
you've used this analogy so many times
and it that's just because it's so
salient and it's so relevant and
young people today that are especially
um millennials gen z and generation
alpha for sure
understand this more than the older
generations do
but the idea that that we ourselves
are as a as a desktop user interface or
as a
as a virtual reality uh headset
that we ourselves when we use these
objects like this glass of water i know
that i
sip from the glass of water and it gets
me the fitness points in terms of
not dehydrating and continuing to live
so that i can procreate
um now now that object has a higher
weight
than does the object of me reading about
sri aurobindo and the mother mural fossa
and their understandings of metaphysics
and so so the idea is that this is an
icon
in my in my on my on my user interface
on my multimodal user interface it's an
icon
but underlying this icon at the very
depths
which we're which we'll get into here in
a moment there is some sort of a
there is some sort of a source code of
that object i don't manipulate the
mathematics the voltages the transistors
etc i don't manipulate those things just
like when you play grand theft auto
or world of warcraft or minecraft you
yourself
don't go in and you don't when you drive
a car you're not manipulating the codes
that do the left all you do is you turn
left in the car
so that sort of these theories around
desktop
interfaces these theories around virtual
reality headsets
um it's interesting because they're what
is kind of the cutting edge
technologies that exist today but also
they are in a sense the most
relevant ways of of conceptualizing
this theory and i think you did a really
good job at putting them together
in order to get this interface theory of
perception in order to get this
conscious agent theory but that's this
general idea is that there is some sort
of uh
of us of an abstract mathematical source
codes that are occurring
that are then creating some sort of a
holographic space time
uh for us to then be conscious agents
inside of that then we interact with
uh the user interface of objects for the
fitness points of procreation is that
approximately correct
right so so that's right the theory of
evolution of natural selection
clearly entails that our senses have
been shaped not to show us the truth
whatever the truth might be and by the
way
to prove the theorem we didn't have to
actually assume we knew the truth
we could prove it without knowing what
the truth is which is very very
interesting that mathis
allows us to do that but it and so it
the theory of evolution with natural
selection clearly entails that
um using the kind of metaphors you were
talking about
it's not like our perceptions were
shaped to be a window on the truth
they're more likely to be shaped um
as a user interface like a game
interface to a computer where
if you're as you say as you're playing
grand theft auto
you might have no idea that there are
voltages and magnetic fields and
insides of trillions of of you know
silicon uh you know transistors and so
forth
in a computer you would have no idea
that that's what you're really playing
with
and as you said um from an evolutionary
point of view
there's um very little constraint
on from natural selection for us to
want to understand ourselves at this
deeper level right it's in some sense
if you've been trained to play a game um
you might not
be inquisitive about who wrote the game
and so you
know if you ask most kids who are
playing games who wrote it that was like
i don't care what oh do you know about
the voltages and magnetic fields so who
gives a rep i mean it's
i just want to play the game and so you
can there is
some notion from evolution that might
point in a different direction and that
is that
that our species from an evolutionary
point of view is
a bit unusual in that um
many species occupy a small number of
niches very maybe very specific niches
and they have a limited set of fixed
strategies that only work in in certain
small niches
and we've evolved
a frontal lobe that has the ability to
make models
and we can play with these models of our
environment
see what would happen in various
circumstances and
see if we would be injured so we could
die in our model
as opposed to dying in person in in the
environment and so
one could imagine how that kind of
capacity which was originally evolved to
model
our environment and how it's hurting us
or helping us
that we could then all of a sudden sort
of co-op that to reflect on other things
right we're model builders
and all of a sudden we start to wonder
and and part of the thing is
there's a sense in which we want our
models to be right
because if our models aren't right they
won't protect us right so there is
again going to be this built-in
wish that for us to have good models and
so one could
go and interact in that direction and
try to come up with an evolutionary
story about how our species might be
sort of selected to want to have some
kind of notion of truth that sort of
maybe
builds on this model building thing
which wasn't about truth it was about
staying alive
but there was a sense of truth of the
model in the sense that it's
it's the true way to play the game right
so there's this true
i mean if i'm playing grand theft auto i
would like to know that if i turn the
wheel left
my car is not going to go to the right i
mean that's that's a true model within
grand theft auto it's not true in terms
of the diodes and resistors and the
voltages
but it's true within the context of the
game and so one could
try to tell craft a story like that
where evolution sort of shaped us to be
model builders in the game and we wanted
our model of the game to be accurate and
that then extended to
a few people more philosophically going
whoa
um could this just be a game and could i
try i mean to to get a model of it so so
i'm not saying that that's a true story
but i'm saying it's
it's an interesting way that we could
try to go within the evolutionary
theory but i do want to say that the the
next step that i've taken about
conscious agents is entirely independent
nothing about conscious agents is
dictated by the theory of evolution by
natural selection
all i'm doing there is i'm saying
evolution
by natural selection is telling us that
there's a reality
that's different from space and time and
physical objects
it's utterly different from it and
so as a scientist i'm trying to think
okay well okay
so it's not space and time and physical
objects what is it
and since i'm interested in
consciousness and what's called the hard
problem of consciousness how our
conscious experiences like the taste of
chocolate and the smell of garlic
related to brain activity and i'm trying
to solve that problem
that's why i sort of said okay let me
propose that
consciousness is the fundamental reality
and as a scientist i need to
give a mathematically precise definition
of what i mean by consciousness and so
it ended up being as i studied it with
my wonderful colleagues jayton prakash
and
manish singh and chris fields and and
others
who work with me it's not by any means
by myself alone
that we came up with sort of this
network model of it's like a vast social
network of conscious agents
but that's a separate hypothesis one
could
buy the argument from evolution of
natural selection that we don't see the
truth
and then say but i don't like your
theory about conscious agents i'm going
to
something else for the reality so that's
perfect or you could say i don't like
any of them but then
to look at the theory of evolution of
natural selection and
and and figure out what you think is
wrong with my theorem yeah
i'm glad that you're bringing up
the sort of
whatever we end up hypothesizing
as an ultimate reality that is beyond
what seems to be
just a a user interface that
whatever we hypothesize as that it must
unfold a
quantum field theory a space time and an
evolution by natural selection
so that's really some key is that
whoever
is trying to conceptualize whatever it
may be at the most abstract mathematical
level happening it has to unfold
um those three keys but it also it also
has to
uh unfold um
the conscious agent's experience
that has a a combinatorial
essence to it that um that
i interact with the cup i drink the
water that's a very very
common experience amongst conscious
agents is drinking water
it's a lot less of a common experience
among conscious agents to have a rube
goldberg
book or music or company idea
and execute that into the world so there
are these rarities
and then there are these more
commonalities i want to i want to ask
you
about um would it would it be fair to
also
kind of call this like in a
you know is this is source code an okay
word for it is implicat like david bowm
would say is that an okay
word for it are these okay
interchangeable sorts of
as long as we recognize they're just
metaphors i mean the the real
point of the theorem for natural
selection is that
there is a reality whose structure is
utterly
unlike any structure of our perceptions
almost surely
and so so you so we can use various
metaphors
and the source code is a great one if
i'm thinking about it as a user
interface absolutely
david baum's i mean a brilliant
brilliant quantum theorist um his
implicat order
trying to think out of the box um there
but as you
as you pointed out um whatever
we put in that deeper realm whether it's
source code or
implicated order or in my case a network
of conscious agents
um if we're going to do science
we can't just wave our hands we have to
have a mathematically precise statement
in my case of conscious agent networks
and as you
pointed out then um there have to be
testable predictions that in principle
could disconfirm
um what i'm proposing and so
there's a some several things that that
any
real scientist would require of of my
theory
they would require that you know at some
point before we can really take it
seriously
you better show how space time emerges
and when you show a space term emerges
you better get the sciences that we have
with space time you know
general relativity special relativity
quantum field theory
or generalizations of those theories but
but but you can't do worse you can't do
worse than those stories you've got to
do those theories are better
and also evolution by natural selection
and so so this is not uh just well
i think it's consciousness and wave our
hands and so forth we have some hard
work ahead
to to for example make specific
predictions about
how the dynamics of conscious agents
can tell us precisely the say that the
amplitudes for scattering events at the
large hadron collider
but we have to be able to do that kind
of of concrete prediction
eventually i mean i can't do it right
right now i my team we're working on it
but
but i absolutely accept that until we
have that kind of
prediction testable prediction um we're
not there yet
yeah i want to let's let's go into
the um the abstract mathematics
first and then i want to go into the um
super macro scale conversations around
um the infinite candy store analogy
we'll
get there in a moment so
okay in terms of the math of
the conscious agents um we're running
what uh john maynard smith this
evolutionary game theory style
evolutionary simulations and there's
there's
there's several components to it and
correct me
if if if i'm wrong and then if not we'll
have you elaborate on it
would the first component being a
category theory
and that basically being like the agents
themselves um and the
uh multi-agent reinforcement learning we
could
we could say maybe um then we have
markovian morphisms the markovian
kernels
we have the the explorations that are
happening
um we kind of called this the earlier
you were talking about like a monte
carlo tree search and a model based
reinforcement learning
um style for the agents to explore and
morph
so the actual sets of the agents
um those sets those category sets they
morph over time
based on the experiences that the agents
undergo
and then there's a replicator equation
for procreation
so it's three so it's three things the
replicator creation procreation
and i believe you said that you don't
have the quasi-species model yet which
is for mutation
but that though that these are kind of
would you say these are kind of the
abstract components is the category
theory the markovian morphisms
the replicator equation the
quasi-species model is that
approximately
the right ballpark well certainly that's
that's
true when we're doing our um simulations
just of evolution by natural selection
right so
so john maynard smith transformed
darwin's idea into beautiful mathematics
back in the 70s and this is called
evolutionary game theory
and so in fact i used i and my graduate
students uh
justin mark and brian marion used john
maynard smith's
you know evolutionary game theory to
first run simulations
before we had the theorems we ran the
simulations just to see if it was worth
our time right you know you
you just want to see what's going to
happen before you spend your time on the
math
especially when you have limited math
talents like me so so we ran the
simulations first
and there we did find that uh you know
organisms that saw reality
virtual organisms in our simulations
that saw reality went extinct when they
competed against ones that
of equal complexity that saw none of
reality and were just tuned to the
fitness panel so that's what led me to
then go to a real mathematician chaitan
prakash and pursue
the the theorems now in the case of the
agent dynamics
um i'm not wedded to evolutionary game
theoretic
kind of model of the dynamics of
consciousness
i have to be open to a much wider
range of possible dynamical systems
right interesting
it's in general going to be simply some
kind of dynamics on graphs
so the general mathematical arena is
these
graphs and dynamics on graphs which is
a fairly recent and quite complicated
branch of mathematics now one constraint
will be
that whatever dynamics i come up with
the conscious agents
when i project it into the headset into
space time
i need to show why it looks like we get
john maynard smith's
specific kinds of evolutionary dynamics
in the headset
right that has to come out but i don't
have to put it in
to begin with in the level of conscious
agents and that would actually be more
impressive if i had
some more general kind of dynamics or
some kind of different dynamics
and that then very interestingly when i
project it
looks like evolution by natural
selection and the evolutionary game
theoretic
so right now i'm just pursuing but
category three i think will be a big
part of it right
right now we we're using markovian
dynamics
on on graphs um
but we we're thinking that for
the bigger picture of how agents
interact and combine to form new
agents we may have to go to a category
theoretic representation that that's
more general than the markovian dynamics
that we're looking at right now
so maybe manoidal categories to begin
with
is so so so interesting so um
the so the co so conscious agent theory
the conscious agent dynamics
are occurring on graph and on
yeah that and that's kind of the them
and then the conscious agents get
described
the allen conscious agent gets ascribed
a a a a category set
of of of um
for example like your your dna may be in
there something a lot
something like that maybe your your your
the the morphisms that that that that
agent undergoes
may be like we described earlier this
most
common morphism of drinking the water
which then
enables the agent to live another
day because they've imbibed water versus
having the you know the rube goldberg
transcendent
idea of a business that they build
uh incessantly obsessively over five
years
actually gets them a very serious
long-term
fitness payoff so and which gives them a
better
uh a better stance on the hierarchy for
in the replicator equation the gen their
genetics
will mate with a better uh partner's
genetics is it is it taking in that that
level of process
eventually of course we're going to i
mean that's what we see in the
interface right we see this kind of
evolutionary dynamics and we see
genes we see dna we see this
the replicator equation we see
reproductive success and failure
um and so those are things that that
will have to show at least are the way
from the point of view of our our space
time headset our interface
but that's the way this dynamics looks
to us through that but it may be
that it's that that that point of view
deeply misses a lot yes completely
misunderstands what's really going on
with this whole realm of conscious
agents so
so i don't want to in any way restrict
my imagination
about the dynamics agents to anything
even about
sexual reproduction and fitness the
whole notion of fitness
and and so forth may be only an
artifact of our headset
just like space time space time itself
the very structure of space time
is an artifact of our headset it's not a
deep insight into reality
so that's the the weird thing and the
fun thing about the challenge of this is
so when when i go after this theory of
conscious agents and then you're asking
exactly the right questions to
to really expose what it means to try as
a scientist
to go to a level of a theory that goes
beyond space time right
you you have to on the one hand be
constrained
ultimately by empirical things that we
can measure inside our interface
like dna and you know fitness
and survival and so forth but our ideas
can't be constrained necessarily in this
deeper realm
we really have to let our imagination go
and ask
the really tough question which is first
you know
what kind of deeper theory do we want to
go after so i'm going after a theory of
conscious agents and consciousness
others that have
i should mention tried to go a different
way i mean so seth lloyd
was looking for something beyond
space-time and he proposed quantum bits
and quantum gates so
so then that's mathematically precise
and so there's this just
abstract world outside of space and time
with these quantum bits and quantum
gates
and he was able to show how with each
quantum
gate the action of the gate um
corresponded to
the curvature of a little patch of
relativistic space time you know
gravitational general relativistic space
time and he could get
um he could sort of boot up general
relativity from this this deeper
reality now you could of course ask him
why in the world should it be that this
deeper reality
is quantum bits and quantum gates who
ordered that and why why why should that
be the deepest reality
and we could scratch our heads about
that but but and that's a legitimate
question
but i'm just saying that once you go
and say space-time isn't fundamental
there's a lot there's
countless ways that we can go as
scientists to look
and so for me so it's a non-trivial
choice
to say i'm looking for consciousness and
my motivation was
simply because i think i'm conscious i
think you're conscious
um if i'm wrong about that and i could
be wrong about that then um
why i'm wrong about pretty much
everything um
and so i i decided i wanted to propose a
theory in which consciousness is
fundamental
um and see if i couldn't do the hard
work of showing that space-time
emergence is just a headset to represent
all these this
this think about it as a big social
dynamics like the twitterverse
yeah so they're proposing this big
twitter verse of conscious agents
and but since it's you know like the
twitterverse there's tens of millions of
twitter users billions of tweets
what do we do is that you can't interact
with all the tweets or the twitter
users we need a visualization tool to
see what's trending
in new york delay zoom out what's
happening in the united states what's
happening in europe what's happening in
china
zoom in what is you know what is alan
tweeting right now so i should
a good tool would let me zoom in to just
alan zoom out to what's happening at the
whole united
united states that's what our headset is
right now my headset
is representing most of the conscious
agents with really dumb symbols like
tables and chairs and so forth not
because tables and chairs are conscious
just like if i have a in my headset i've
got something that's representing
what's trending in the united states you
know some red
objects are doing something over here in
green option it's not that
red object and green objects are
conscious or twitters that's just how my
interface codes the stuff because it has
to give up
but i'm not giving up so much when i
interact with you i'm actually
interacting with a specific
consciousness
and you're interacting with my
consciousness and so so our headset
in many cases will just use really crude
symbols that we call just
inanimate physical objects that doesn't
mean anything deep it just means that
our symbols are have to give up
right there's no in this point of view
there's no fundamental distinction
between living and non-living
that's we think it's a fundamental
distinction in reality
it's just where our interface symbols
are
more or less insightful about the
conscious agents that we're interacting
with
so so there's no fundamental principle
distinction between living and
non-living and there's no way that life
just boots up from the unconscious
ingredients of our interface
so this changes the whole the whole
point of view but to get right back to
your your question
what we have to do in this theory of
conscious agents in this dynamics
is not assume john maynard smith's
theory
we have to get it coming out as a
projection of a
deeper dynamics and so we have to ask
and this is the really fun part the
creative part for scientists
you have to ask um every theory
has certain assumptions what are
and we want to have as few assumptions
as possible right because
everything you assume you're not
explaining so right every
every time you put something into an
assumption you're saying
can't explain that so that's an
assumption so you want as few
assumptions as possible
and and so there's no theory of
everything right there is no scientific
theory of everything because
every theory has some assumptions that
will not be explained
by that theory so there's there are
theories of everything except my
assumptions
that's that's what science says we have
theories of everything except my
assumption
and of course then you can get a deeper
theory which tries to explain those
assumptions but it'll have its own new
assumptions right and so science always
will have this limit that
we only have theories of everything
except my assumptions
and so i so my theory of consciousness
is no exception i will have a theory of
consciousness
except my assumptions and so my
assumptions are that there are conscious
experiences
like the taste of chocolate the smell of
garlic a headache
and that those conscious experiences
can affect
other conscious experiences so they
inform
actions that affect other conscious
experiences that's it
that's i just want to say those two
things so it's i mean so notice i'm not
saying
anything about a self or self awareness
or self consciousness
not saying anything about memory or
learning or intelligence or problem
solving
there's all these things that i'm not
saying they're not they're not part of
the kitchen sink that i'm throwing into
my theory
these are all things that i'm saying i
will have to explain
the only thing i'm going to let my self
have is two things
there are experiences and
experiences in form actions and the only
actions
are to affect other experiences that's
it
with those so that that minimal
structure my hope is to say
um i can then give you a theory in which
we build
ourselves as data structures we have we
can build theories
out of networks of so this is going to
be the dynamics of graphs there's going
to be
graph dynamics in which we show how to
compute
things like memory learning problem
solving intelligence and so forth
and and by the way uh it's a theorem
from
our mathematical statement of the
assumptions i just gave you
there are experiences and they can
affect other experiences
by writing it down as markovian kernels
as we have
it's it's a trivial theorem that um
this framework is computationally
universal and what that means is
um in principle there is
no limit any theory that we could build
of learning memory problem-solving or
intelligence using computers
i can build with my theory of conscious
agents if you can do it on a computer
i can build a theory in this new
language of conscious agent
networks so that's so so i know from the
get-go that i have an adequate
but minimal set of assumptions that lets
me build all these theories i can build
a theory of learning memory problem
solving
myself and so forth out of this
the two assumptions that you made about
experience being fundamental and also
about
experiences uh impacting
each each um other agents that then
impact their actions
um that those are
pretty fundamental also to um
ancient spirituality perennial wisdoms
around the planet which we'll talk about
also um later
so i appreciate how you say that
there's there's many different ways to
up the source code mountain and okay
i i yeah yeah i i like that a lot
there's a lot of
um like brian keating just had stephen
wolfram and um eric weinstein on and
they were
uh talking about the the nature of
mathematical reality and they were
they were talking about the the hop
fibration
and they were talking about how um that
vibrational
data is um is is is a
is a big deal and it's happening in
that's happening infinitely far away and
then it it
the emergence of it and and um
and and to me um that
style of thinking and visualizing i
think is also important i don't know
where that lands on on the mountain
towards the source
code um and where that would incorporate
a a conscious agents
or or or if that would happen downstream
or whatnot so for
i really appreciate how there's many
different ways
up the source code mountain and that
there's different ways to
um just to speak about and visualize it
then there's there's well
let's um let's mention let's mention
this um
you gave you gave a really good just bit
there
um a moment ago on how the
the the conscious
agent does not see
the i think this this is extremely
important but like the reign of photons
that are coming right now
and this big um field of nitrogen and
oxygen
uh molecules in front of my face um
the electromagnetic spectrum that we
only see from 400 to 700 nanometers on
um the fact that we
don't see any of those things is
precisely be because
we potentially designed it this way so
that
we could act
in the ocean of that we're in
uh to have
experiences because if you couldn't have
those experiences
if you were blocked by the ocean
of the electromagnetic spectrum and the
sea
of oxygen and nitrogen that you're in
does that generally about right too
right from an evolutionary point of view
that would be the kind of argument that
um you
you want to evolve sensory systems that
tell you what you need to know
to act in ways that will keep you alive
and you know that'll keep you fit
but um you want to do it as cheaply as
possible right
every calorie that you spend on
perception
is a calorie that you have to go out
kill something
and eat it to get that calories so there
are selection pressures for
to to dumb things down to keep our
senses as simple as possible
um given the the other pressure of they
have to be complicated enough to
accurately report fitness at least
more accurately and and more fitness
than than your competition there's
there's nothing that
in evolutionary theory that says that
you are perfect about seeing fitness
either right so i'm not
i'm not being um a theorist that says
we're we have vertical perceptions of
even fitness payoffs
there's nothing vertical here anywhere
we we have what we call
satisficing solutions in evolution right
is good enough
to just beat the competition and so so
in
from that point of view from an
evolutionary point of view and again you
can see my attitude is
look i'm not saying that evolution by
natural selection is true
but i'm saying we have no better theory
right that that is the best theory we've
got so
so until we have a better theory we've
got to take it very very seriously
in what it says and then try to break it
right i mean
the icon so we have to respect it really
study it
and then also try to break it so so what
that theory is saying
is yeah there's no selection pressures
for you to know everything
quite to the contrary all you need to do
is be a little bit better than the
competition
and so why should we see the the the
deep structure of
atomic nuclei or the the wavelength
structure of photons and so forth
and and the fact that we in science
uh you know run into these things
is is interesting what we're doing
is we're studying our headset right
our headset has evolved with certain
structure to it
like we have us a space time that we
perceived intuitively you know three
dimensions of space and one dimension of
time
but when we actually study our
perceptions more
systematically we we realized it was you
know einstein comes along and
and uh comes up with surprising
features about our interface that
eventually lead
to posing that there's a minkowski
structure
to space time and then eventually even a
curved space time
he comes up with a curved space time and
then when we so
what's happening is we're taking the
language of our senses the language of
our interface that was evolved
and what science has do has been doing
is studying our interface we haven't
been studying
objective reality we've been studying
our interface and its structure
and even microphysical particles like
quarks and gluons and leptons
are the physicists will tell you they're
just what they call
irreducible representations of the
poincare group but that means
that they're they're representing
symmetries
of space-time we have this space-time
format for our headset
and particles are just representations
of the symmetries
of that of that formatting system and so
so yeah we haven't seen all this stuff
and until science came along
and it and what science has been doing
is systematically exploring our headset
um and and and it's taken a lot of hard
work right you
thousands of brilliant scientists
working really really hard
which gets back at your main point which
in some sense from evolution
we weren't evolved to see this otherwise
it wouldn't be that hard we would just
see it
so so why it just takes like it takes an
einstein
it takes you know we the people who
actually figure this stuff out we
we view them as absolute geniuses right
they mean that
because in some sense the rest of us
mortals
would never have even thought of that
and so there are a few of us
like the einsteins and the john wheelers
and
and and so forth who have these really
deep insights
um and then the rest of us um you know
feel smart
by association yeah it
absolutely a power law of uh brilliant
people that have pushed the edge of what
is known one billion people have been
uncommon and 99 billion people have been
common and um yeah yeah and the ones
that are
uncommon are the ones that make the
mutations
on that uh universal constructor um
that we're a part of and then that tape
uh then a hundred years later we're all
flying airplanes you know
uh style um
yeah the um the the other
the other thought for me around um
the perception as you were indicating a
moment ago
which i think is really valuable is that
when
when when one augments their user
interface when one augments their
perception
um in a sense what they do is they they
kind of like
climb the ladder of abstraction um
but what happens is they like they see
the world in a higher resolution
like when when we're talking about the
electromagnetic spectrum and the sea of
of oxygen nitrogen et cetera that that
is that's here the photons etc
all all that all that would we've done
is we've conceptualized these things
then we've
stored it but then we don't continue
seeing it all the time
so yeah so so this is a key insight i
think is
you rise to the levels of abstraction of
knowing this and then you
store it as a concept so like you double
click in you see the higher resolution
and then what you do is you zoom back
out and you've stored that data and then
you go about your
the rest of your um the whatever the
function is and like
you described earlier there's many ways
up this mountain so
we're not just saying that it is only um
procreation
but that is definitely high and uh truth
is also
high the more that you know about truth
the greater chance you have of getting a
mate as well
um but people that are tuned
specifically towards
um fitness payoffs like you indicated
versus just truth payoffs um fitness
payoffs will win out
um over that but there is there is an an
overlap
there but i i appreciate that that
understanding of of
upgrading perception and then and then
holding that as abstract concepts
that you can access any time versus not
even having
in fact yeah that that's a good point in
the sense that um
even the best of scientists when they
reach
some deep new understanding like quantum
theory
and you find that that these electrons
and photons are
in superposition states and they get
entangled and so forth
um the best and brightest you know like
richard feynman will say look um
if you think you understand this you
don't understand this no no one
understands this this is just
this is mind-boggling stuff and and so
these geniuses who
who are at the forefront of understand
working on it will will say that it it
just
shatters all of your your intuitions and
from an evolutionary point of view you
could say well
no surprise i mean we weren't in some
sense evolved to understand
the subatomic world and and so our
concepts
and intuitions just aren't matched to it
and when we get there
we get there by mathematics right the
the
we're forced to these conclusions
because we
we try to get some mathematics that will
explain our experiments
when we get the mathematics and finding
oh wow finally an equation
that matches the data so what does this
equation entail
it entails that are you you got to be
kidding me it means that there's
superpositions
that there is entanglement i don't even
know this is
it and so then you have the really
brilliant people going i have no idea
what what this really means all i know
is that that's what the math
is saying and my intuitions are are are
boggled and so
so that's that's where we are
on that and
they're in terms of
perceiving the truth and and getting
mates
um yeah mentioned um
from an evolutionary point of view there
is an interesting
for our species um
there's an interesting sexual selection
pressure
so a male
that has special linguistic
or cognitive abilities can
by showing off perhaps be more
attractive
to females that's just one way that you
can show off you could also show off by
being physically strong
right and fast faster muscle there's
never ways of showing off but
but there are some selection pressures
for for women to
be more attracted um to
to males with better displays of
cognitive abilities
and and that can lead not necessarily to
truth
but to just making up really impressive
stories
and and just trying to look impressive
so
so the alphabet soup logical fallacy
right so so they're they're you know
just
performing in a way that makes you look
impressive
may or may not be necessarily moving
toward the truth now in the case of an
einstein right um
but if you've stored this data like if
you've stored the quantum field around
the tree with the
exchange that is happening of
photosynthesis between the human and the
tree in terms of o2 and co2 if you've
stored that data if you've stored also
how you eat the apple that's went
through the
photosynthetic process of making the
glucose and then you eat that and you go
through the cellular respiration process
if you've stored these pieces of data
and you know them and you can recall
them
they give you a scientific and a
spiritual
fitness advantage in that sense over
other potential mates for
whoever that that doesn't know that data
absolutely in the following sense i mean
knowing that kind of stuff i i know
um things that could change my behavior
so that i would eat more healthily
and and and be more healthy that way or
i could
devise new technologies that allows me
and my tribe to beat the others
and and therefore be more fit in that so
absolutely that's one thing that's
driven
science is the need for technologies to
fight
other human beings um so a lot of
i mean so and it works right it's you
know
the united states is the world
superpower not because um
we're the smartest people or the
strongest people or the bravest people
we just happen to have the best
technology that that's that's that's it
that's so it's really in that sense the
fitness
in an evolutionary sense goes now with
great
technology in the past it was um you
know who knew how to throw
sticks and and rocks better and then
figure out levers and then bows and
arrows right
that was a you know bow and arrow
unbelievable technology
it gives you an incredible advance until
the other tribe figures out oh
look what they did and they so now you
get this arms race and so that
is so you're right that there is in some
sense this this
fitness payoff for better and better
technologies absolutely and and that
is one of the selection pressures uh
sexual selection pressures
women will be impressed not just with
brawn but also with brain
in our species yeah so
so interesting on that point um
let's um let's talk about um and
everything that we just mentioned would
it be fair to say that those are
upgrades
in perception in your multimodal user
interface that
these are upgrades that we can make like
if your dashboard
sees like from the old school days of
how to make the bow and arrow
or from today's modern day maybe you
know how to use python to program a
computer
that may be that if you have those
little icons
on your multimodal user interface that
maybe then
in this interface theory of perception
if i can perform some mimesis and i can
learn how to do the bow and arrow or i
can learn how to do the python
programming and add that to my
multimodal user interface perception
that then then that is
the upgrades in perception augmentations
and perception that enable me to climb
those ladders of of fitness and
abstraction and truth and stuff like
that
that that's right it's it's an upgrade
not in the sense of the basic hardware
of the brain right the
the hardware of the brain that you got
is what you've got
but you can because our our
our brains are have evolved to be
learning algorithms and when we we learn
and build models
and if a lot of other people around us
that we see
have figured out models that we might
not have figured out on ourselves
we can effectively be more smart because
we can instead of figuring ourselves we
can just
adopt their model now we have their
model even if we weren't smart enough to
actually figure it out
ourselves and so as our population has
gotten bigger
seven billion or eight billion and so
forth you know right there's there's a
we have that many people out there
there's going to be some some real
geniuses
who will come up with big ideas like
there'll be ann einstein
and we we all talk about einstein
and there are a billion other people
that we're not going to talk about from
from 1905
um that that and but the
zero to one and then the one to many as
peter thiel would say
yeah that's right but there is a i'll
tell the opposite side of this now and
that's it's it's quite remarkable
um our brains in some sense are not
upgrading
they're downsizing that's right yeah
what is it is it the volume of a tennis
ball
we've lost in the last 20 000 years
that's exactly right
um so the peak
was 15 20 000 years ago and apparently
then
what seems to be going on um well
what what is going on in the data is
that they can measure the
the volume of the of the skulls the
cranium so that you can measure you know
the brains are gone but you can see
the volume that they occupied and so you
can actually measure we've lost in the
last
15 20 000 years um 10
15 of our our brain volume of the
the about the entire volume of a tennis
ball is gone
so it's it's truly stunning and and
apparently we got smart enough 15 000
years ago
to create agriculture
and with agriculture we started to get
now
with to support agriculture you need to
bring
um a bigger social group we have small
social groups as hunter-gatherers but
now you need to
bring together bigger social groups and
you had to have a bigger division of
labor because
you know we had to be you know tending
the crops
working on the crops we could then
we needed people to defend the crops
because the hunter-gatherers are going
to come through and just try to steal it
from you right so you got to
now you have to have a standing army
they can't be always doing the crops and
so
you get this division of labor that's
that's coming out but once you get a
division labor
um i don't have to be smart about
everything now if i'm a hunter gatherer
me and my small group
we have to do everything or we die right
we have to make our clothes
we have to take care of ourselves when
we're sick everything that we need we've
got to do ourselves or steal from
somebody
and but you know greater selection
pressure for being a polymath 20 000
years ago and then the slowly
we've relieved those selection pressures
today
where you're just exchanging the sheet
of paper for the apple
instead of growing it yourself yeah yeah
an iq of 70 and just go to the store and
get my food
as you know i mean iq 70 probably you
know
during the 15 000 years ago i would have
been run over
so it's you know it's so it's a use it
or lose it
kind of situation or use it you only get
it if you need it and since
um i don't need to do everything i don't
need to be a genius at everything
as much as before i'm not and so our
brains are being downsized
i i as as also we're at least
you know we have this access to the
internet and we're moving into the
genetic engineering the neural
prosthetic ages
that we're getting potentially the
assistance of these
agi coaches and we can maybe learn how
to augment our working memory
to 20 um plus or minus two and maybe we
can abstractly reason
such novel concepts that have never been
thought of before
and um but so maybe there is a way to
kind of bounce
back from that loss uh maybe um
that would be that would be good um and
yeah yeah um let's let's this is good
that that was a good bit
on those um augmentations i definitely
think that
um there's many other um augmentations
that
that exist like entheogens is a is a
prominent
um augmentation that exists um deep
the depth of meditative experiences the
deepest steps of those as well
um augment one's perceptions also enable
them to
really understand what the pause is
instead of being so reactive they can uh
they know how to slow down and just
observe and then
um which is game changing for your
relationships with your family your
friends your co-workers
people online blah blah and so all of a
sudden
just from something that doesn't appear
to have
a high fitness payoff right it doesn't
appear to have a high fitness payoff but
really when you learn how to pause
instead of immediately react
um it gives you tremendous fitness
payoff
downstream i i i would agree
in in the sense that especially like in
our society right now
right um most of us
aren't facing on a daily basis um
immediate threats to our our bodies but
it is you know there of course i mean
there are many murders in the united
states and around the world but
but it's you know as as pinker has
pointed out
stephen pinker in some of his books um
the rate of of
homicide is dropped dramatically over
the centuries dramatically
and and so we have the luxury now
of not having to
look over our shoulders every moment you
know
worrying whether some other human being
from another tribe
is going to be attacking us or so forth
and so
so it's it's it's interesting that
if you're in a situation where you're in
a war zone
and um there are imminent threats all
the time
then being anxious and being alert
is very very fit right it's very very
important
eventually that anxiety and the cortisol
that it produces will kill you
but it won't kill you today and it will
keep you alive today so
in that sense it's more but now we have
this luxury
we're not an imminent threat there's not
imminent danger
so if we're in the state of of high
stress and anxiety
and so forth producing cortisol all the
time we are unnecessarily shortening our
lives
if i was in a war zone i would be
necessarily shorting shortening my life
but to stay alive today
so so with meditation and so forth
we can move into a greater sense
of peace and reduce stress and anxiety
we can reduce our cortisol levels
um and we can enjoy that that state of
life
now it's because of our you know from an
evolutionary point
of view um we are programmed
with a stress system right we have an
amygdala we have all
they're there um because that's what
kept us alive
we are the offspring of those who are
anxious enough
to be able to face the threats
successfully right so
that's why we have this proclivity to be
anxious
um there are variations among us but as
i mean
there's this video i saw in some
national geographic
show about nature or something with a
bunch of monkeys in the wild
but they're all the monkeys are up in
the trees and and gluten hollering and
so forth
except for one this one monkey was this
really relaxed laid back monkey out in
the grass
on you know and while they're filming
they happen to
some tiger or panther comes along and
guess who he got
yeah yeah that that relaxation gene just
went out of the gene pool
it was the only it was only the monkeys
that were uptight and
scared enough to stay in the trees
that's that that passed on their genes
and so
so we we are the offspring of those who
were are you know anxious enough
so so from an evolutionary point of view
um there's a clean
reason why most of us
face stress and anxiety even when we
don't have to right
we feel it when we don't have to so
evolution you know programmed us that
way but but meditation
is something that we can now do when we
have the luxury of not being in a war
zone
not being attacked all the time then we
can you know take the bull by the horn
and say look
um i don't need to be anxious all the
time even though i've been programmed
by natural selection to be anxious i i
can choose
to meditate and literally reprogram my
brain circuits
to be more relaxed and i will
enjoy my life more and statistically i
will live longer
yeah yep
yeah there's there's many of
variables in our user interface that
sometimes seem to
not have a high fitness payoff but
they're because most of the high fitness
payoffs just
appear to be the short-term
gratifications
um and also the um
uh things involving money but the
things that are sometimes involving
learning
how to do things that are maybe
thousands of years old like
learning how to investigate your own
consciousness and awareness and
calm down and become more peaceful and
joyful
that uh doing that doesn't seem to
immediately have a
monetary or fitness payoff but it but i
think there are many things like that
that exists
that get you closer to truth get you
closer to peace and joy
that actually do give you better
downstream fitness payoffs because
that's the thing is that
mates given procreation
men and women both that don't have
as keen of an interest for
truth um they're they in a sense
it feels like there's less soul there
there's more soul with people that have
a depth
of interest and truth and also we as a
society need to do a better job at
creating the economic
incentives that make it so that young
children
can explore metaphysics and
consciousness
as a profession and get paid for it too
so if there's
you know money intertwined with truth
more carefully
then maybe some of those conscious
agents could win um
over people that just focus on fitness
um and
and and money so yeah absolutely and and
um again as i said before you know i as
a scientist i'm always
just sort of saying what different
theories entail right
so i've been very very careful to say
that this is what evolutionary theory
entails and so forth
but but i don't necessarily believe the
theory but now what you're saying is
very interesting suppose
you know no not forget evolutionary
theory suppose that
there's a deeper theory in which
consciousness is fundamental
and in some sense maybe this dynamics of
consciousness is really
what it's about is the exploration of
consciousness that's what's really
deep meaningful in this deeper realm of
consciousness right
and and so perfectly right
then puts a very different spin on the
whole meditation thing than the spin i
just gave right the spin i just gave was
from an evolutionary point of view which
says
uh it's just a way of countering the the
built-in anxieties that we have and
so that would that was that was you know
bracketed within that theory so now i'll
put that theory aside and say okay
that's what that theory entails
but there's this other framework
entirely different in which
consciousness is fundamental and it's
what it's all about
so in that case then meditation might
not be just this side little issue to
make us more
comfortable be that that's
only that's when we really wake up to
what we're really about that
maybe we're immersed in a game but the
point of the game isn't to win the game
maybe the point of the game is to wake
up yeah
realize who we are and maybe playing the
game is a way
of more more deeply understanding um who
we are as conscious beings and and so
maybe
most of us just don't wake up in this
game so but again notice
i'm not saying that i know that this is
true and and that's the key thing
dogmatism from my point of view is the
is the
the worst thing we we could ever have
yeah baptism assuming that i know the
truth
is the way you stop inquiry so so i
always want to say
this is now i'm bracketing it with this
theory in a theory in which
consciousness is fundamental
then it would it would have this
different spin on things
and so that's what we we should always
even if that's right you can never know
that you're right that's the weird thing
about this so this is the human
condition
we can never know for right we can find
out many cases
that were deeply wrong but but we can
never so
there's this deep humility that we need
to have in anything
that we claim um it's rather
the way i like to think about it i
propose the theoretical framework in
which i'm going to speak
and then say within that framework this
is what it entails but of course the
theory could be wrong so here's
here's what evolution entails here's
what the theory which consciousness is
fundamental
entails um but but maybe both theories
are deeply deeply wrong and so then
let's talk about a different framework
right and and so that's how we we yes
yes
the theories as opposed to being
attached to them yes
it's an anti-dogmatic kind of point of
view it's more
um exploring and and
if we assume that we know then we cut
off inquiry
and we can't learn if you know if you're
certain that you know
then you're not going to be motivated to
learn
yeah this is paramount um balancing
excitement with non-dogmatism because
you have to have confidence in
what edge you're trying to push and you
have to have humility
as well uh exactly exactly
that's that's the knife edge i agree
with you
it's not easy for us to to maintain that
but it's really critical
it's so so critical um but because
especially
sometimes young people are are trying to
push with confidence something that may
be
actually really critical to get to the
edge and beyond the edge
but then there are influences of maybe
parents or community or friends
that are just hating on them um
moving that forward and so that there's
also the importance of of that of that
confidence and encouraged to to get
to to that edge and to to push it and
rocket it forward
it's very important oh absolutely i
think that that you've touched on a
really important point i mean
so the the theory that i'm working on
right now i i'm excited about it
i've got energy you know i think i'm on
to something
but and so you and you need to have that
kind of energy and that kind of
enthusiasm to push forward right
but then i always step back and go but
of course i could be wrong i mean i hope
i'm not but you
but you know you have to have that that
that dual understanding about the whole
situation so yeah be
motivated be excited but but not
dogmatic that's the knife edge
yep yep those are some of the codes that
we are archiving
from the dirty bath water is the
dogmatism and the fundamentalism and
we're
taking the baby out the the scientific
method we're taking out the
hierophanies these sacred divine
communions and experiences subjective
ones that people do have
and sharing those better um
i want to talk about the triangulation
um so there's obviously now we're
talking about math we're talking about
science we're talking about ancient
spirituality
we're talking about consciousness uh
we're talking about
all of these uh sacred sorts of
um especially the last
thousands of years this is from axial
ages
explosion through scientific renaissance
and
explosion there and scientific method
and whatnot
coming together and triangulating on
what this nature of reality
is and that i think it's interesting as
we were talking about the source code
mountain and all these different ways up
in exploration
we we kind of we we
we may have mentioned this slightly um
that could it be that
the uh that the ancient
perennial spiritual wisdom of everything
being
one integration everything being one
thing and then also having the small
derivations like a calculus of
consciousness they're small derivatives
of us nerve endings uh
having the conscious agent experiences
and interactions and
that cause actions to change and whatnot
that
that the triangulation of that
and on um the science
that is being pushed uh from like your
conscience agent theory and many others
are just pointing at this the same thing
over thousands of years or we're coming
to the same thing and that kind of
maybe indicates that there is that one
mounted top with many different paths
i wanna i wanna see um what you think
about
the the candy store analogy is very
strong
it's it's very strong the the candy
store
um analogy for the conscious agent
experience and my question would be
would be this i've i've been
i've been struggling with trying to to
understand
this that for thousands of years there
have been
ancient spiritualities that have talked
about how
everything that is possible
already is that's what infinity is
infinity is everything that is possible
it's all the combinatorics that are
possible
are already happening and and the
being becoming is the only being
so it's just an infinite amount of
becoming always eternally happening
and that all the combinatorics that
exist do but then there's kurt gertle
and there's this incompleteness theorem
and
there's this idea that it's it's
impossible to ever
be everything it's impossible to ever be
all the combinatorics possible
so are we are we are we
already exploring all of the
combinatorics of the infinite candy
store
always and always will um or
can we never explore all of the
combinators of the
infinite candy store and therefore um
and and and maybe um the oroboros
could i can bring that in as well just
that that as we evolve to whatever
the godhead attractor is that we're
going towards
maybe the recursive function is to just
continue tasting more of the
candy store combinatorics as conscious
agents and that's
that transcension hypothesis at the
godhead that we just go inward for more
exploring so
take us on that journey of those two
options and then on we'll get to that
recursive godhead
right so girdle
when he was only i think two years old
we're 25 years old
25 yep crazy in 1931
he he did one of the most brilliant
things
ever in human history he
proved his incompleteness theorems and
and
effectively what he showed was
that if you have any set of like axioms
assumptions for a mathematical system
that's rich enough
to do arithmetic then he showed that
there will always be
statements that are true mathematical
statements that are true
but you cannot prove from your axioms
that
the so these are unprovable truths
they're trues that are unprovable
now you can imagine the genius that it
would take to prove that there are
unprovable truths what he did
and now if you take those truths that
are unprovable
and add them to your axioms you might
think oh
well then i'm done but then he proved no
there will be yet new
truths that are unprovable within the
richer and so
what this means is that there is no
end to exploration of mathematical
structure
it's and it seems
to be an unending
exploration that that even an infinite
wisdom
could never get around right that
there's a sense in which
you can't ever be smart enough to
comprehend the whole thing this is this
is pretty deep this is
an exploration that in principle appears
to never ever be possible to stop
impressing like the infinite um benoit
mandelbrot fractal zoom
that's right but this is the kind i mean
there if you take
the um the real line from zero to one
there's
points but yeah you can see them all
right
there's some sense in which it's
comprehensible this is
different this is like yeah it's it's
unending and
so now how it relates to the
consciousness stuff and what you're
talking about is
um if now i'm again
bracketing with respect to a particular
theory right so suppose we adopt the
theory in which
consciousness conscious experiences are
fundamental
right so then in under that idea
mathematical structure is only about one
thing consciousness and conscious
experiences
and in that framework then you would
girdle would be telling us that there's
an infinite variety of
conscious experiences with an infinite
variety of different structures
and and that may be a little strange to
a lot of people to talk about
experiences being structured
right but if you if you think about just
your experience of
the world around you there's up down
left right forward and backward there's
there's a structure a three-dimensional
structure to your to your space
and and there's a structure of color
space it turns out that
for example red is a little bit closer
to orange than it is to
blue right there's this there's there's
a closeness relationship that colors
have
in our our perceptions and everywhere
there's a field called psychophysics
that's been around since 1860. a guy
named gustav fechner started it
but in that field what we do is we study
conscious experiences
and their structure and their structure
all over the place so
all conscious experiences they're more
than mathematics
so no consciousness experience is just
mathematics
but each conscious experience is
structured
so i like to think of it is that the
conscious experience
is to the mathematical structure like
the living organism is to its bones
so it's like mathematics is the bones of
consciousness
consciousness is not just his bones it's
it's much richer than that
but it's not less than his bones it it
it has to have the bones as well
so so what girdle is telling us
under this theory that consciousness is
all there is that's this fundamental
is that there's this infinite variety of
conscious experiences with an infinite
variety of
structures so that's what i call
girdle's candy story
because these are now things to be
experienced like candies right you know
the kid in the candy store was like let
me try this one oh that was great now
let's try this new experience now i love
chocolate well
i like caramel too and so what girdle is
inviting us in this in this framework is
to say that
there's this infinite range of conscious
experiences and
no consciousness of any type
even the most glorified can ever come to
the end of the exploration
and so there will be this endless
exploration
of all the possible forms of
consciousness that we could actually
think of girdle's theorem
is telling us that that what it's about
is consciousness
learning more and more about itself as
it explores more and more of its
possibilities
but it will never end and um and we're
all
perhaps our
quote-unquote we are that we are that
yeah
the um we are that or i and my father
are one
yeah that that's right and we're
exploring it in a particular minkowski
space format
with objects in space and time and this
is the particular little
so but that's what that fits in with
this headset idea like so instead of
taking space and time
as the final reality in this bigger
girl's candy store picture it's
no this headset that we've assumed was
the final reality
is one candy in an unbounding candy
store it's just one
and what so part of the waking up
is to recognize this rookie mistake that
we took this chocolate
as the only candy in the store this is
the whole thing it's all about chocolate
well now it's not all about space and
time
and what's inside space and time that's
just one little headset one candy in the
candy store
wake up to all the infinite
possibilities again
you mentioned you mentioned this earlier
something like a walt disney or a pixar
style imagination
where if you do imagine what it is like
to
evolve a headset that is non-carbon
based dna coded beings in a space-time
quantum field theory soup of natural
selection
that then maybe you can you can envision
what other
simulated uh designs of of realities
look like uh and you could even wander
just a couple solar systems over and
think about what it would be like
um you could even stay in this universe
if you want and you could
explore what what uh alternative
so so does it does it feel like that
then
we are already
all of the infinite candy store
combinators always happening or that we
can never
be that and we are always endlessly
exploring that
well girdle seems to be saying we're
endlessly exploring and
and that that you're right that we
can certainly try to imagine and explore
outside of the standard space-time kinds
of things
um but there are certain interesting
limits
to this too that we have right now so
for example if i
this is one of my favorite examples of
this if i ask you to imagine
a specific color that you've never seen
before
oh yeah but does anything happen
suppose you're colorblind right so
you're you're a guy you're red green
color blind
and and so there's this whole range of
color experiences that you can't have
that
you know every almost every woman has
and and color normal men have
so there's this red green distinction
that you don't have but if i asked
a colorblind man to imagine red
well he can't do it right just like you
can't imagine a new color
i can't imagine a new color so if so
there are some
really if i can't even imagine one
simple color i i know colors right i've
had lots of color experiences
but all my imagination does not allow me
to imagine it's outside the color wheel
right yeah really well i can't i can't
do it and and yet
we know that there are creatures um for
example there are some women
who have four color receptors not just
three
so most of us have know a long medium
and short wavelength cone
but these women have apparently two
versions of the long wavelength cone
and they and in some women there all
four of them are expressed in the retina
and when you do careful tests on these
women so kimberly jameson
of a phd researcher here at uc irvine
who i know has she and others have done
careful tests these women
give clear evidence that they're
that that can be interpreted that
they're in a richer color world than the
rest of us
just like us trichromats we are in a
richer world
than the colorblind men these women are
in a richer color world than us
so they're having color experiences
that i can't even imagine i can't
imagine what they
i can imagine abstractly that they're
having them but i can't imagine
concretely any one of those experiences
and so that's the limit that we're going
to have right now it appears
yeah our understanding of the
possibilities and some says
we can understand abstractly
the possibility of all these realms of
all the candies in the candy store
yeah but until you taste the candy
[Laughter]
like yeah four percent of people are
synaesthetes and
um there's creatures that see in the
infrared and on the other side on the
ultraviolet like there's a different
species umvelt so the different
um yeah so species are wearing different
headsets and we could
you know we can we took the uh channel
rhodopsin for optogenetics and we took
um the the uh
the green fluorescent protein gfp for
the
um for other biotech work that we've
been using so
we've we we're borrowing from headsets
uh from
like user interfaces to yeah so
um this is very good if you can't
imagine outside of the color
wheel um of our user interface
then it's hard to like walt disney or
pixar yourself
out of uh into like different universe
designs as well
but um i think virtual reality does a
really good job at
trying to slowly in a sense kind of like
stretch out your color wheel beyond um
because when you're when you go in and
these things are just getting more and
more indistinguishable
so that inevitably it's gonna lead to
a point where um where you may
be um spending um
your your your 80 years
engrossed in the game because we've also
hit the longevity escape velocity so you
can now live
because we're just home we're just we're
just we're just engineering
out any of the disease we're just tuning
the car or the plane
um we give uh to like 15 year old
homeostatic capacity of our body over
and over again
so you can play for those 80 years and
then and then take it out and then just
be like wow that was vanilla that was
great and now it's like
back to uh carmel for now and then uh
yeah
yeah yeah so yeah i think vr will help i
agree
it'll help stretch our imaginations and
help to take us in different places and
i think it will also help
um to understand
the possibility that what we assumed was
the objective reality space we
would assume the space and time and
physical objects the sun and the moon
and stars
these are the absolute ground of of
reality
and but someone who's actually you know
the next generation that sort of grows
up and spends a lot of time in
virtual realities that are just as
immersive and compelling as everyday
life
it's it's got it's not going to be you
won't have to be really
a genius to take off your headset and
just wonder well what about this this is
this is just another headset i mean you
don't have you won't have to be an
einstein to do that it'll just sort of
be like duh
you know of course it's a possibility i
mean if if i can
if i with this headset in
creating all these worlds that aren't
there then surely i'm creating this
world around me and it's not there
either
i'm i'm the creator of it whatever the
reality is
this is just a headset to that reality
so i think it will really help our
imaginations that way
but in terms of concrete imagining of
specific new kinds of color
or other kinds of experiences i don't
know
short of taking drugs that sort of like
you know open the doors of perceptions
in certain raw ways
and maybe meditation could do that
there may be some technology that will
do that but what we have right now
the way that scientists do it is we go
there
with mathematics we let mathematics
take us so for example can you imagine a
three-dimensional cube sure
can you imagine a four-dimensional cube
nothing happens right
einstein had to be thinking in four
dimensions to write down
his you know equations for general
relativity he had to have a
four-dimensional but he couldn't
visualize it
so the mathematics was allowed einstein
to go
where visual imagination couldn't and
now we can go five
six ten dimensions in mathematics and we
can go
there even though the mathematicians
will tell you they can't visualize
anything and yet there's a way
that our imaginations are going there
because we have this cognitive lever
this tool that takes our our
ability to only concretely imagine three
dimensions
and leverage that into the abstract
ability
to work in any number of dimensions but
we can't visualize it
and so that's so we can use mathematics
to
explore abstractly what's in girdle's
candy store
but it won't actually let us taste it
wow okay so we will
be able to make
all these novel combinatorics of candies
um the trick is going to be to enable us
to actually
taste right that's right that's right
just like you mean the simple problem
you can't you know imagine a specific
color you've never seen before
and nothing happens yeah if i discover
all these new structures that
consciousness can have and say okay
well imagine what it's like well you
concretely
won't be able to do it just like you
can't imagine a specific color
so so what we can do in some sense
what we're getting from the mathematics
is boy are there all these
really really intriguing candies out
there that are beckoning
yeah and uh i'm telling you that they're
there but you can't taste them right now
yeah yeah yeah there's there's all
there's this
um there's this an an
infinite um catalog
of of valence of of conscious experience
that is available of such
wild combinatorics that are way beyond
our own color wheel and tastes
of candies um that right now we're just
talking
about but that nobody has tasted or
experienced and so we want to
we want to just shatter that and send
lots of conscious agents out to
experience
that right and that's from this point of
view from this framework
in which consciousness is fundamental
that's what consciousness is up to
it shoots all sorts of explorations and
you and i are just some of those
explorations we're exploring this
particular
candy in a particular part of the candy
store and we're using minkowski space
and physical objects to do it
and um and most of us have no idea that
there's anything else right this is the
only candy in the store and
and we're happy but this is one of the
boundless candies and
um it's it's fun to wake up to that it
may be frustrating too if we sit here
and going but oh
but i can't experience them and by the
way
even the mathematicians based on girdle
is incomplete this term
even the mathematicians can't abstractly
even begin to explore just the
mathematical structures
right but by the way this is great job
security for mathematics this is
provable job security
this is you will never come to the last
theorem
never so this is sign up for being a
mathematician because you know
that you have endless employment
agi will help us uh create those
novel um theorems that help push the
edges
further i want to i want to ask you
about um
that oroboros so at it does does it then
if we are um creating the
the if we if we are a
one that is having the um dissociative
as bernardo castro talks about
experience of
of the nerve endings that we are having
the experience in
in the reality that we ourselves have
designed and made that then
um that we of course must not get lost
in the own
um in the own infinite labyrinth of our
creation but we must
um go towards that that whatever
attractor of a
of a star that we're all in a sense like
orthogenically
um building towards right now and is
that star
that we're building towards is that a
recursion is that the transcendent
hypothesis is that
all of us as conscious agents
going through the process of
making more experience
tasting more of the candies in the store
so is our recursive godhead function
to just taste more candies in the
infinite store that we will infinitely
forever eternally be exploring well
that is the kind of idea that that i'm
i'm pursuing here so
so absolutely and and this but this
question really touches on
something that you brought up before
which is that there are many wisdom
traditions over thousands of years
that have said very very similar things
and and and and in some sense as a
scientist
i'm sort of a johnny come lately right
science is sort of a johnny come lately
to this but
but the science is is coming along but
but the kind of answer to the question
that you just raised
will require that we
take all the insights from the wisdom
traditions
and then we also take the rigors of the
scientific method
in terms of theory building and careful
testing
and bring these together in a
a synergistic interaction so that we
we find out from the wisdom traditions
deep deep insights but they they were
there first in
terms of saying space-time is not
fundamental like the physical world is
not fundamental
and they've given us some informal
pointers
to what might be beyond right there's no
mathematics there there are
right so now that now the johnny come
lately
science and okay we now
now we realize the space time is doomed
that there's something deeper
and we can now start to build
mathematical models that try to capture
some of the insights of the wisdom
traditions
and we can have this back and forth now
between our intuitions on the one hand
and then our attempts to make them
precise and and why do we do that is it
just to be pedantic
and to be you know over the top with
mathematics it's not that at all
it's that in some sense
you don't really know what you're saying
until you say it so precisely that you
could be wrong
that's when you are beginning to know
what you're saying so
we will use in informal words you know
in in the wisdom traditions including
words like god
and if i ask you precisely what's the
definition of god you won't find it
anywhere so um
what we need to do is
to try to make these intuitive ideas
that the
traditions have they're probably genuine
insights make them absolutely precise
so that we can then learn and be
surprised like
so for einstein for example in i think
around 1907 or so he had this
fundamental insight about gravity
that if he was in something like an
elevator that was free-falling
that you would you would find and you
had a you know
something that could weigh you in the
elevator you'd find that you were
weightless you wouldn't weigh anything
inside the elevator
and he said that was like the happiest
thought of his life because it was
it was the insight that gave him the
general theory of relativity but it took
him something like
eight years of
struggle really
tough emotional struggle sleepless
nights
pulling the hair out kind of kind of
stuff to turn that
insight into finally in 1915 or
something like that
he got he wrote down the equation and
that's what it really means to say
if i was in an elevator i would be
weightless but what it
and the reason you do it now is because
then the mathematics
is smarter than the person who wrote it
down
that mathematics that einstein wrote
down
he didn't know it but it entailed
the existence of black holes and when
someone else
a year later after he published it some
some guy in the front lines of world war
one actually working on the equations
discovered um this guy named
schwarzschild
discovered this solution to einstein's
equations
that there are these black holes and
einstein did not like it he disbelieved
in black holes for decades
so here's a case where we write down our
we take our ideas including these deep
spiritual ideas that we've had for
thousands of years
we write them down mathematically not
merely to be petatic so that we can
actually learn what we were talking
about
all along falling in an elevator and
being weightless means there are black
holes
well who would have ever figured that
out and so the things that we say in the
wisdom traditions
they're going to mean all sorts of other
things that we had no clue that they
meant
until we get serious and write them down
so that's why
i want to see this synergistic
interaction between science and
spirituality where we take the insights
from the one
and the rigor of the other and then
we learn we get surprised that's that's
that's the hope
wow yeah that's so well articulated
um the you you said this in another
um in another way as well that you
become a student of your theory that
the equations become smarter than the
genius that wrote them down
that right you're just it's so spot on
um that that the the the flag that we
plant beyond the edge
of knowledge that we create hypotheses
towards
that just flowers a whole nother field
that we
weren't ready for we didn't know yet
existed and
the signs of spirituality are those two
driving forces that have
gotten us um so far and that
to where we are and so to bring them
together and harmoniously test them i
like using the
the description where you think about
like would have we done the manhattan
project and dropped
nuclear bombs on hiroshima nagasaki if
our science community was a little bit
more spiritually ethically
morally philosophically awakened but
would we also s would we would we um
would would we have all of the pedaling
of snake oils
if our scientific method was stronger to
analyze those
um snake oil salesmen so there's there's
that
as well so they're these things they
they they come together
like peanut butter and jelly okay
they could and i you know there's been
this long-standing um
antipathy between science and
spirituality that
has some interesting historical roots in
particular for example the
the treatment of galileo by the catholic
church
i mean and and and alan turing even in
the last
100 years yeah and that was yeah
that was um a society that was
um that really cruelly attacked him for
being homosexual sexual
yeah right so so in in so
so there's been this long-standing
antipathy between
science and spirituality at least since
galileo and the catholic church
and and
giordano bruno burned at the stake
exactly that's the kind of stuff that
that
that we don't want to have happening and
and that's why
it's it's really critical to walk away
from dogmatism
yeah right that's that's dogmatism is
the source
source of all this and you know it seems
like um
[Music]
most spiritual traditions would
recognize that that humility
is a virtue and i would include
in that humility about my beliefs
humility that i could be wrong and
especially when we have hundreds of
different religious systems
many of which in the past have said that
i'm right and all the other religions
are wrong
now now we know that at most one of
those hundreds
could be right right and and what's the
probability that it's mine and so
so instead of going in that whole
framework it's rather
why not have an attitude of what
whatever
the ultimate reality is surely
there's compassion for my ignorance
and for what i got wrong and there's it
it's
and surely the the the most
healthy way for us to proceed is to
listen to each other
and to share i don't have to believe
what you say you don't have to believe
what i
say but but i also don't need to kill
you if you just disagree with me you
don't need to kill me if i disagree
you know and instead we can have this
this humility to listen
maybe agree to disagree um and then
maybe later on in 10 years i realized oh
i was deeply wrong and you know
sharon over there she was deeply right
and i just didn't see it at the time but
i've grown up and now i see it
so so just giving ourselves the time and
the space
to to grow up and to to learn
uh humbly and and that's the way i feel
about
the science i mean i i'll say this
i love scientific theories the i study
them
they're incredibly beautiful and i don't
think i've ever seen a true
scientific theory i think all scientific
theories that i've studied so far are
deeply false
they're the best we have so far yeah but
they're good enough
in many cases to tell us where they're
false
and that's the power of a theory where
it tells you
where it gets off and that's what i want
in spirituality
there's a therian spirituality that's
good enough to tell me
where it is inadequate and where it's
beckoning me
to now go for a deeper theory with a
different level of understanding
but it's all new inadequacies and girdle
is suggesting that
we will be doing this forever
don i feel like the
the edge pushing that's happening around
um bringing together science of
spirituality the edge pushing
that's happening around um understanding
our source code
um that that the topics that we've
talked about
and understanding that ultimate
reality um i i feel like
um the word integral and integrality
are a very important um phrase there
because of
um just the integral and the derivative
but the integral in the sense of the
integration of
all um perspective but the derivation in
the sense of the
um each one of us having a unique
experience in that candy store
um so yeah yeah and and in a unique
artistic contribution or gift to bring
to the world and
and um that that's that's the 99.9
genetic similarity integral and the
point one percent genetic difference
differentiation
um so that yeah yeah go ahead
absolutely i i think you've raised an
incredibly important point to view each
person that you meet
as a gift they have a new perspective
that's different from yours and rather
than
putting up barriers to things that are
foreign and novel to recognize that
here's a chance for me to explore
something
that i that i might not have ever ever
explored
without interacting with this person and
you
this person maybe i'm a geek that likes
mathematics
and this person is an artist who likes
painting and photography
um i can learn from their perspective
and they can learn
from mine and and i can appreciate um
if i'm willing to open up and humbly
listen and and really
listen because i may not have the
concepts yet
i may not have the point of view to
really understand what that person is
saying
yeah in which case um it's even
more important for me to put in the time
and effort because i'm gonna have more
to learn there there's more
that i can can grow from that so so
having that kind of view of our
differences that they're an opportunity
to learn
to expand our horizons um
and to realize that that in some sense
perhaps is what life is all about is
constantly expanding our horizons and
constantly
enjoying new vistas yes this is that
we've had
we like to sit in our own vestas and say
this is it yeah hey you know that next
mountain may have something even more
fun
yeah the constant exploration of the
infinity candy store
i love this it seems to make the most
sense um of the alternative being we
already are
all of the infinite candy store
combinators
um eternally happening and that has a
little bit more of maybe a
a nihilistic eternal return sense to it
that we've been here before we're doing
this again um
but the the other one the idea that
there is
just it's never going to end the
infinite exploration
um it has a little bit more adventure
and it has a little bit more
darwinian metaphysical implications to
it as well where
um we need to take this seriously we
need to take our
um rock orbiting of the star very
seriously because
um if if as above so below another
spiritual wisdom
is true that's also scientifically
validated that if natural selection is
happening here between
us natural section is all could also be
happening at this cosmic level not only
in our universes but universe says
competing um against one another for
that recursion and
how likely it is that that they
themselves get to those next
tastes in the the qualia uh
candy store that's quite possible that
would be something i would really like
to explore
in this dynamics and graphs of conscious
agents to see what
what in the world's going on here and
what kind of dynamics are we using maybe
to explore the candy store absolutely
yeah don i'm so so grateful for this
conversation
thank you thank you for everything that
you're doing and that you've inspired so
many people to
think in refreshing and new ways and
push the edge of what's known
we're very grateful to you thank you
into all your lab
to all your students and lab and
teammates um as well that that's very
important the people behind the groove
of the song
right oh absolutely i couldn't have done
it without my graduate students and my
my collaborators you know you know
and i could name a bunch of them that
frankly um
push my ideas around all the time and
that's how i learn
thank you thank you so much and thanks
everybody for tuning in we are
super grateful for you we would love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
on the episode let us know what you're
thinking
check out the links in the bio below to
both don's website
also his book the case against reality
check that out the book links there it's
one of the best books i've read would
love for you guys to check it out and
enrich yourselves with it and share it
with other people as well
also check out the link to don's twitter
profile as well that's in the bio below
and also support the artists the
entrepreneurs the spiritual leaders the
scientists
around the world that you believe in in
your community support them and help
them grow you can find our links in the
bio below to our show
you can help support us as well paypal
patreon cryptocurrency all those links
are in the bio below
and go and build the future everyone
augment
that source code tape and uh and build
the new the new uh deployments of of
code into our world you can do it
uh we know you can be the michelangelo
and be the um the elon musk and be the
the be the ones that are just pushing
the edge to rosalind franklin's
um for all our females out there of
course um
you know be be that be that change maker
um and uh and and and do your best to
unpack what our ultimate reality is
along the way
so much love thank everyone for tuning
in and we will see you soon
peace
[Music]
you